again forgiveness I'm probably gonna be
wearing this and having this shouted
extra videos I think I'm gonna watch a
few of these in a row because I have a
lot of cons coming up so I'll do my best
but okay so for this one we got uh Zuko
alone just that title you just saw go oh
this is gonna be a good one first of all
I love Zuko of course the character is
just a wonderful character um and in
this episode we get more of his
backstory we get more of the
relationship between Alec I see him in
the sister but not just that just that
whole world of his family and his
friends and I'll be honest when I first
saw or heard the voice of Azula I did
like the voice but I was saying to
myself you know this almost seems a
touch to it maybe a little to show off
II that I'm evil and it almost seemed
like the character was written away
where she would be so confident
and conniving and she wouldn't need to
show off but when you see this backstory
and you see what she's like again you
see the progression into this character
if anything it's impressive that she is
as conniving and intelligent and devious
as she is because you see quite clearly
that she is just this very nasty brat um
who just gets the sick joy out of misery
and it's again that this isn't our
character it's like oh I can't wait to
see more about her because where did
this start because we see clearly uh the
family is run by a nice mother it's a
very kind you know mother who also has
issues with the zoo wondering how how
did this happen even she sees she's
losing control and and that can be very
difficult
whatever gonna go even more into that
but Azula seems to be very much she
wants to be like her father where Zuko
very much wants to be like his mother
and there's a scene I recall where the
uncle sends Azula he sends
Zuko a knife this very honorable weapon
a sense Azula a doll you know it's a
very fashionable doll and what I like
about this is this could very easily be
seen as oh he doesn't take women
seriously or thinks they should be then
some other plays or something like that
but when you see the characters you know
that's not the case first of all there's
tons of women in the it looks like
there's tons of women the fire army Fire
Nation army whatever so it doesn't seem
like the uncle would be like that second
when you see what she's like you know
he's trying to encourage Zuko to be
probably stronger as well as honorable
because he's he knows there's a chance
with him we're with Azula she is so far
past gone and just getting worse and
worse that he's trying to bring her back
to that innocence I know it sounds like
a probably reading too deep into it
maybe I am but I think by getting her
the doll that's what he's thinking
because he probably knows okay this kid
like you had to come back to being a
child okay you know because Zuko is
being treated very nicely and he's
acting very nicely back uh you know and
he is confused and sort of lost and the
sister seems to have found her place
it's just a horrible terrible place and
unfortunately it's very much following
alongside what the father thinks so we
got this backstory going on then we also
have Zuko trying to it for lack of a
better term discover himself he's trying
to find his path he's trying to grow
stronger on his own a finds this family
in the the earth Kingdom I've discovered
to call my that all these people are
like it's not earth nation I'm okay I
said it wrong but dude so many people
got angry at that I don't know I I got
it wrong so I know it's earth Kingdom
I'll try not to call the others water
nation or whatever you know they call
them the Four Nations in the opening
that's why or was it for king of
well anyway bottom line earth placed
Zuko's in earth place and he comes
across uh these people who are these
soldiers who are not nice soldiers
they're bullies they're thugs again I
really like this they're not going all
the kingdoms are nice and all the people
are nice of just the big bad Fire Nation
there's good people in the Fire Nation
there's bad people in the earth Kingdom
and so on so forth again it keeps it
it's not so black a white I really enjoy
that
so you got you got these thugs being
real jerks and zuko sticks up for this
kid doesn't quite fight them which I
like and makes it very clear that he
could and even the the soldiers they are
intimidated by him like they'll they'll
take stuff from him but they won't hurt
him they won't fight him uh it which I
enjoy they see okay this we don't know
who this kid is a has the scar but he's
gonna fight obviously this kid is not
afraid of getting in fights so let's
let's be careful here so he befriends
this this family because he stuck he
still confirm this kid stood up for this
kid and him and the kid there for me
started this nice friendship together
he's getting along with the family uh
suddenly the soldiers come they take the
kid away they say well if you're old
enough to try and just miss misses and
yelling as you're old enough to fight
we're gonna turn you into a soldier
comes get Zuko says Iggy I don't know
who else to go to it you just you got to
help me they took our our son away so he
goes has this badass battle I believe he
revealed who he was was how worth he
revealed that he's Prince Zuko you know
he's been banished and stuff that this
is who he is he is found his identity in
a sense like you know he's admitting who
he is he doesn't care who knows it and
that comes at a great price
everybody hates and now even the people
he just befriended despised him uh it's
very much Frankenstein which is it's
just more tragedy more angst more uh but
it works I the one the one thing I
thought
a little stronger is that he made such a
connection with the kid I would have
liked him maybe the kid was a little
confused he didn't know how to feel and
then maybe the grown-ups sort of told
him more who he is or what he's done and
that turned him into hating him I don't
like they just turned on a dime
especially because his life was saved by
him um I know that's the idea that it's
the harshness of prejudice but I I would
have liked if there's a little bit more
of a transformation there and Zuko walks
into the sunset ah food so a great
development story I do they explain what
happens to the mother I was kind of lost
on that if she goes up to him while he's
asleep just bad stuff apparently is
going down you know the grandfather is
dead or is going to die the grandfather
does not like what the what Zuko's
father is saying and proposing and even
though he kind of seems like a very
aggressive man he still has his good
side
and does not like the idea of totally
turning aside the uncle and instead
putting who's going to be the fire Lord
as fire lord zuko father uh he passes
away maybe good possible plot but it is
so he passes away the sister is thrilled
they evil little I hope I go into that
more and I like to know how she became
this my guess would be she hangs out
more with the father
but regardless uh the mother is very
supportive and very kind leads and says
just know everything I've done I've done
for you sir puts his cloak on it and
goes away and all they ever say is just
that she's not there she's gone I don't
know if that means she left she was
killed she killed herself maybe that
something is gonna be revealed in the
next episode or down the line I'm not
sure I haven't but I wish they left a
more obvious whether or not that was a
mystery which of course I'm sure
everybody the comment is now gonna say
no no it was this or it's supposed to be
that so regardless that could have been
a little bit more clear to me you
probably noticed an edit there because I
actually it wasn't because my wife
walked away they I actually went to
check on the name of the voice actor I
you know I know it's whatever rufio but
I wanted to get his name right as name
is Dante Bosco and I wanted to get that
name right because this name really
deserves to be known and I say that
because this person got something that
so many big-name actors try to get and
it's what actors like Kevin Costner and
Russell Crowe and Daniel Craig John
Wayne all these actors try to get this
and so rarely hit it in my opinion but
this Dante Basco guy he hits it so well
and that is the brooding honorable
warrior and what he gets about it is
that he focuses on the tragedy and not
the brooding and there's a big
difference when you see this character
of Zuko go up and everything he says you
can tell this is a very this is a very
dramatic very tortured character but
he's not doing it to show off and he's
not dead to the world either he's he's
somewhere in between trying to be
something of worth and shutting off from
the world altogether and there's that
battle constantly going on in a search
for trying to find out who he is a lot
of actors try to get this by just
talking monotone by just acting like
well I've given up to the world that
shows undramatic
know this guy gets it and he does it so
superbly well and I think the fact that
he was obviously born with his very
young sounding voice guys older than I
am
uh and he has this voice and he's using
it to his advantage I love people that
take something that many would see as a
disadvantage and they use it to their
advantage you know Peter Dinklage
another great example I mean they just
own what many people would say would
work against them and they make it not
only not work against them but
work for them and I love what this guy
is able to do with this character I mean
on top of it it's a very well-written
character and almost all the voice
actors in the show are superb but if
this guy particular I think really
captures something that like I said is
so so marketable in big blockbusters we
always tried to capture the quiet
warrior who's brooding and trying to
look dramatic and squits the eyes and
frowns and only once a while might give
a little bit of a smile because they're
so tortured and drama and we love all
that but I really think this guy gets it
and he nails it and in my opinions very
rare that you see that you only see them
with really really great actors and I
really think he nailed it in this in
this performance and a lot of people
would say well just because he got here
doesn't mean he's that great cuz it's
just voice acting I really disagree I
think with voice acting it's even
tougher because you have to get it all
out simply in the vocals you don't have
any facial expressions any body movement
any of that all of it has to come from
the voice and this guy really nails it
and he does a wonderful job so in this
episode particular I mean it's it's been
that way through all the episodes but in
this episode in particular I really
wanted to point that out I really wanted
to give this actor credit because any
show or movie even plays to a certain
extent are very much a collaboration of
writers and directors and actors and so
forth but every once a while an actor is
allowed to really really shine and you
can just tell no this wasn't just good
directing good writing good
cinematography good artistry this is
good acting and like I said I really
just wanted to give kudos to this guy
because he really creates a wonderful
character here along with the writers
but it is a very specifically well
hammered out performance so I just want
to give kudos to him
um so yeah that's about it just another
really good strong episode I'm looking
forward to see if they go even more into
the backstory I'm sure they will because
I anything was do coincidence his name
was in the title it's just like going
love Zuko so um yeah again I love here
and uh anything about that character and
I look forward to anything about all the
other characters cuz I love all the
other characters so I will see you in
the next episode take care